tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel à
fontenay le fleury un policier gênées
par le brouillard tue l'un de ses
camarades
l'enlèvement du milliardaire hollandais
moque car en deçà une question se pose
s'agit-il d'un rat politique ou
crapuleux pris 0 9% en septembre
c'est officiel un véritable conseil de
guerre se réunit à matignon la semaine
prochaine paris poitiers en moins de
trois heures pour 54 francs et pourtant
certaines autoroutes françaises sont en
difficulté financière
un temps incertain pour ce long week-end
de la toussaint
bonsoir dans l'édition de poche qui
viennent paraître du rapport du comité
présidé par alain peyrefitte et intitulé
réponse à la violence
le premier chapitre est consacré au
sentiment d'insécurité en france à la
réalité imprécises
à l'image subjective de la criminalité
une représentation de la société comme
une société de violence tend à se
propager
elle reflète partiellement la réalité
c'est dans le texte mais d'une certaine
manière s'ils intègrent aussi l influent
à son tour sur les comportements voilà
une constatation de ce rapport publié en
juillet et qui oriente en ce moment déjà
un certain nombre d'actions du
gouvernement très certainement le
sentiment d'insécurité va au delà de la
réalité de la violence mais quand nous
montrons les faits divers il se peut que
nous amplifions la réalité
vaste problème et si je vous dis cela
c'est qu'aujourd'hui à travers une série
de faits divers ou des policiers sont
concernés
la dominante est bien pour eux aussi les
policiers ce fameux sentiment
d'insécurité à paris cet après-midi des
malfaiteurs qui venait d'attaquer une
bijouterie ont été surpris par la police
au moment du partage du butin dans un
appartement du xxème arrondissement
échange de coups de feu à travers la
porte
un policier blessé un gangster tué à
toulouse hier soir la police avait monté
une opération contre une bande de
malfaiteurs soupçonnés de nombreuses
attaques à main armée poursuivi l'un des
gangsters à tirer sur les policiers
deux commissaires ont été touchés l'un
d'eux blessé grièvement le tireur blessé
lui aussi a réussi à s'enfuir
immédiatement le syndicat des
commissaires de police a déploré qu' une
fois de plus l'un des malfaiteurs se
soient trouvés en liberté à la suite
d'une permission d'autres communiqués
viendront pour dire qu'on ne peut pas
remettre en cause le régime des
permissions sous prétexte que certains
en profitent pour s'échapper
voilà pour les deux premières affaires
la seconde la troisième est ce qu'on
appelle une bavure de la police elle est
très grave
sur le quai d'une gare de banlieue dans
la région parisienne
deux policiers se sont tiré dessus l'un
d'eux est mort l'autre est grièvement
blessé il s'agissait d'une opération
dite de flagrants deal club claude
bertrand les policiers de saint cyr
l'école savait qu'un cambriolage aurait
lieu à la gare de fontenay le fleury
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
prévenue la veille par un correspondant
anonyme il avait décidé d'attendre les
malfaiteurs pour les prendre en flagrant
délit ils étaient 3h40 du matin le
brouillard était extrêmement dense et c
d'après la police cette mauvaise
visibilité qui serait à l'origine de la
tragique méprise postés de part et
d'autre de la voie ferrée les policiers
de commissaires et six inspecteurs
devaient effectuer un mouvement de
taille pour interpeller les malfaiteurs
qui s'apprêtait à forcer le coffre-fort
de la gare l'un des policiers ayant
traversé la voie ferrée directement au
lieu d'emprunter un sous-terrain se
trouve a soudain isolé dans le
brouillard et cru distinguer les
malfaiteurs qui s'enfuyait il s'agissait
en fait de ses collègues venant à sa
rencontre la fusillade éclate à un
commissaire fut grièvement blessé l'un
des inspecteurs qui se tenait à ses
côtés riposta d'une rafale de
mitraillette et tua son jeune collègue
thierry le maîtrise on s'explique pas
comment que ce jeune inspecteur qui à 82
4 mois de service et est plus dégainé et
tiré
sans penser qu'ils ont ils pour y avoir
décollé ses collègues en face lui le
manque de sang froid de certains on nous
envoie la leur les circonstances on peut
pas expliquer dans le comportement de
quelqu'un qui a une arme c'est
extrêmement difficile
autant vous dire comment ça s'est passé
personne ne sera jamais d'ailleurs avoué
qu'il est mort avec tout ce qui se passe
actuellement comme violence comme coup
de fusil dans tous les sens qu'on va
t'attaquer et odf et c'est bien sûr
beaucoup de policiers préfèrent une fois
tiré et pas toujours dans les règles du
droit ni de l'art bien sûr problèmes
difficiles je vois pas là on comprend
pas que les pythies rien comprendre
c'est une nouvelle valise et ordinaire
puis l'heure qu'il est surtout mis
quatre balles à 20 mètres dans le
brouillard dans le corps d'un policier
c'est vraiment ils sont considérés trop
ordinaire
oui aujourd'hui les agents de police
attendait il ya une épilogue c'est une
épilogue à cette histoire les deux
cambrioleurs les deux cambrioleurs qui
venaient d'attaquer le coffre de la gare
et c'est le pourquoi de cette
intervention de la police et deux
cambrioleurs ont été arrêtés sans
difficulté et il n'était pas armé
aujourd'hui les agents de police les
agents de la police parisienne ont
manifesté dans la capitale et en
banlieue ils ont distribué 2 millions de
tracts
le syndicat général de la police qui est
à l'origine de cette manifestation
indiqué hier qu'il voulait notamment
dénoncé l'exploitation de l'insécurité
concrètement s'il revendique sur les
salaires il se plaint surtout ce
syndicat du manque d'effectifs de la
vétusté du matériel et de la mauvaise
image de marque des policiers en
uniforme or justement le budget du
ministre de l'intérieur pour 78 qui pour
la police nationale est en augmentation
de plus de 20% a été présenté hier soir
aux députés christian mas del ça nous
fait regarder ce budget c'est vrai que
le budget 1978 de la police ne répond
qu'en partie aux revendications des
policiers en uniforme en effet ne
prévoit pas d'augmentation d'effectifs
il y actuellement quinze mille officiers
85000 gradés et gardiens pour toute la
france parmi eux quinze mille serre
pour le syndicat général de la police il
en faudrait 25 % de plus essentiellement
à paris car un quart des policiers sont
affectés actuellement à la protection de
bâtiments publics ou étranges
en revanche le budget va améliorer
l'image de marque des policiers première
mort en assurant une meilleure
protection des citoyens par
l'augmentation des émetteurs radio des
véhicules des armes de défense
une expansion de l'informatique
deuxièmement en rendant plus accueillant
au public les hôtels de police et les
commissariats
il suffit parfois d'une couche de
peinture mais il faut souvent
reconstruire des locaux trop vétuste
enfin depuis un an déjà un effort
financier consacré à l'alignement des
salaires des policiers sur celui des
militaires cet effort est prolongé dans
le budget 78 l'insécurité dieu sait
quelle est la plupart du temps bien plus
grande ailleurs que chez nous en ce
moment mais nous sommes aussi
naturellement totalement concerné par
celle qui asphyxie littéralement la
mauritanie avec les opérations des
commandos polisario sur la région de
zouhair hâte après la disparition de
deux nouveaux ressortissants français
hier ce qui porte à 13 le nombre de
disparus dans cette région depuis deux
ans on se demande quelle peut être
l'action du gouvernement français
nous n'avons qu'une certitude la réunion
hier soir à l'élysée autour de monsieur
giscard d'estaing des ministres de la
défense des affaires étrangères et de la
coopération et du chef d'état major des
armées
depuis on a refusé de faire le moindre
commentaire à l'elysée un député
communiste louis au 2 rue réclame un
débat au parlement sur la politique
française au maghreb il se dit inquiet
comme jean paul sartre d'ailleurs de la
réunion d'hier soir à l'elysée
l'ambassadeur d'algérie monsieur
bedjaoui interrogé par france inter a
donné des assurances formelles
officielle et solennelle que les
prisonniers français du polisario ne se
trouve pas en territoire algérien et il
a ajouté que l'algérie était disponible
pour faciliter tout contact avec les
rebelles sahraoui mais il a aussi il ya
aussi cette déclaration de l'ambassadeur
algérien en allemagne qui après avoir
déclaré que l'algérie était opposé à
toute forme de piraterie aérienne de
piste prise d'otage a ajouté qu'elle ne
tolérera jamais l'algérie sur son
territoire une intervention du genre de
celle que les allemands
ont opéré à mogadiscio pour libérer les
otages de la lufthansa
voilà dans quel contexte se présente une
action française éventuel soit pour
aider la mauritanie soit pour eux des
ses ressortissants dans ce pays gérard
saint paul bien le président de la
république et le gouvernement n'ont
certainement aucune envie de déclencher
des hostilités même indirect avec
l'algérie contre les sahraouis c'est une
première chose mais l'état major de
crise réunie hier soir à l'élysée a sans
aucun doute fait un certain nombre de
constatations évidente
premièrement le seuil de ce qu'un état
peut tolérer est largement atteint
deuxièmement la sécurité des français
qui travaillent en mauritanie n'est
manifestement plus assurée à partir de
ce constat d'urgence toutes les
hypothèses à froid ont été envisagées y
compris donc celle de l'envoi de troupes
rien n'est exclu que se passerait-il
dans cette hypothèse du départ de
troupes et de matériel français d'abord
cela ne pourrait se faire qu'à la
demande du président mauritanien moktar
ould daddah pour protéger les
ressortissants français ou les
installations de la mine et de la voie
de chemin de fer ensuite il ne s'agirait
certainement pas a priori d'une
opération commando du style mogadiscio
puisque le désert est immense et l'on
sait que les otages français sont
divisés en petits groupes très mobiles
vivent sous la tente donc difficiles à
repérer et encore plus à approcher sans
danger pour eux car il s'agit bien d'une
prise d'otages politiques de la part des
sahraouis qui revendiquent eux sahara
occidental soutenu en cela par l'algérie
il faut donc se demander quels problèmes
politiques poserait une mission de
protection et de recherche
y aurait-il ingérence française ou pas
dans ce désert du sahara occidental
il est plus juste de parler de confins
que de frontières car les limites entre
la mauritanie le maroc et l'algérie se
perdent dans les sables non le risque
serait plutôt celui de l'enlisement
d'une action difficile à conduire
sur le plan militaire les marocains qui
subissent souvent la guérilla sahraouis
plus qu'ils ne la contrôle en savent
quelque chose
donc une expédition canonnière semble
difficile en revanche une présence
militaire française non agressive et de
protection en mauritanie à titre
d'avertissement pourrait renforcer ce
n'est pas impensable
les dernières chances du dialogue et de
la diplomatie pour sauver la vie des
otages français
tandis que l'on recherche partout les
terroristes allemands de la fraction
armée rouge et sans succès on se demande
si la hollande à son tour n'est pas
atteinte par le même courant de
terrorisme et de chantage à l'enlèvement
un homme d'affaires d'amsterdam a été
enlevé cette nuit à la sortie d'une
boîte de nuit c'est un multimillionnaire
qui a bâti sa fortune sur l'immobilier
son nom moque 40 ça c'est un grand
supporter du football néerlandais
parait-il et de johan cruyff en
particulier aussitôt la presse
hollandaise a reçu des coups de
téléphone qui revendique cet enlèvement
mais jusqu'à maintenant ces appels n'ont
pas été pris très au sérieux et on est
assez sceptique à éric gilbert c'est en
plein centre d'amsterdam comme of 40 ça
a été enlevé vers une heure ce matin au
moment précis où il sans cadrer dans la
sortie du continental club une boîte de
nuit située dans les sous sols de
l'hôtel amstel un témoin l'a vu discuter
se battre avec ses ravisseurs un groupe
de quatre ou cinq hommes qu'ils
attendaient sur le trottoir et qu'ils
ont entraînées vers une voiture au cours
des contrôles effectués ensuite les
policiers hollandais ont fouillé plus
particulièrement les véhicules
immatriculés en allemagne
un correspondant anonyme parle en
allemand en effet téléphoné un journal
pour revendiquer l'attentât au nom du
groupe fraction armée rouge groupe
terroriste proche on le sait de la bande
à baader
mais un autre correspondant a téléphoné
plus tard au nom d'un mouvement 18
octobre pour réclamer la démission de la
reine juliana en échange le monsieur
mode 40 ça cela paraît fantaisiste aussi
on n'exclut pas l'hypothèse d'un rapt
purement crapuleux mode 40 ça que vous
voyez ici est un homme d'affaires à
forte personnalité
parti de rien il a bâti une immense
fortune en commençant pas revendre des
surplus ce avant de se lancer dans la
banque et dans l'immobilier
certains lui reprochent des prises de
positions très conservatrices mais on le
sait aussi généreux il sortait d'une
réception en l'honneur de l'équipe de
football néerlandaise lorsqu'il a été
enlevé et aussi on se demande si ce
n'est pas lié à des problèmes sportifs
pour des problèmes sportifs qu'ils
auraient été enlevées en attendant la
police garde le silence et la famille 40
saâd en elle une éventuelle demande de
rançon
la france et la hongrie souhaite pouvoir
doubler leurs échanges commerciaux dans
un avenir relativement proche
les deux pays veulent aussi intensifier
leurs relations c'est ce qu'a dit tout à
l'heure le premier ministre raymond
barre au cours d'une conférence de
presse à la deuxième journée de sa
visite à budapest à l'occasion de
laquelle il faut bien le reconnaître on
re découvre nous la hongrie un pays de
l'est de ton dont on parle peu depuis
quelques années janos kadar a d'ailleurs
été invité à venir en france de budapest
notre envoyé spécial ladislas de hoyos
21 jan ove cadart dirigeants gris un
homme assez mystérieux réservé et plutôt
avare de sourires que ces ouvriers
portés au pouvoir par les soviétiques au
pouvoir c'est à dire au poste de premier
secrétaire du parti mais aussi un homme
qui est allé rendre visite au pape en
juin dernier et qui par ailleurs a pu
maintenir la hongrie dans une certaine
indépendance du moins sur le plan
intérieur c'est d'ailleurs ce que l'on
appelle ici la spécificité hongroise qui
vu du côté des occidentaux plat ce pays
un peu à part dans le groupe
les adhérents pacte de varsovie tenez
les hongrois ne reste pas bloqué chez
eux ils peuvent se rendre presque aussi
facilement à paris qu'à moscou c'est
notamment ce qu'a rappelé ce matin
janos kadar à raymond barre qui lui
disait à son tour que depuis le général
de gaulle la france a joué un rôle de
précurseur dans les rapports avec les
pays de l'est
il a aussi été largement question du
désarmement et des problèmes
internationaux
le proche orient l'afrique bien sûr mais
plutôt l'afrique du sud ou l'ethiopie et
la somalie que la question du front
polisario et de ses otages français bref
cette essentiellement de la détente dont
il a été question à budapest
ce qui est important et monsieur bédard
l'a bien mieux vaut moins que ma peur
c'est que la détente puisse se
poursuivre de telle sorte que les hommes
puis suivent en sécurité partout où ils
se trouvent
et il considère que cet
approfondissement de la détente sera le
meilleur facteur de l'intensification
des relations économiques et humaines
entre tous les pays lorsqu'il rentrera
demain de hongrie le premier ministre
regardera de près ce fameux indice des
prix de septembre 0,9 pour cent en plus
une mauvaise surprise
la limitation de l'inflation à 10% par
an est l'un des piliers de sa politique
est probablement une de ses obsessions
et pour l'instant la hausse enregistrée
est de 9,7 pour cent en un an de
septembre à septembre
juste en dessous de la barre de monsieur
barre dès le début de la semaine
prochaine le premier ministre tiendra un
conseil de guerre sur les prix
alimentaires responsables en grande
partie des mauvais résultats de
septembre
un certain nombre de produits
alimentaires seront dans le collimateur
comme on dit avec daniel du goût et jean
pierre qui tarde regardons nous aussi ce
phénomène des prix alimentaires qui ont
enregistré des records de hausse avec
0,9 pour cent en septembre
c'est à nouveau les produits
alimentaires qui sont tenus pour
responsables de la hausse des prix en un
an ces produits ont augmenté de près de
15% alors que la hausse des produits
manufacturés se limite à 7,6 pour cent
les services un peu plus 8,7 pour cent
en septembre dans les produits
alimentaires
trois tendances sont à remarquer d'abord
baisse sensible des légumes mais très
forte augmentation des fruits et surtout
accélération de la hausse de la viande
en matière de fruits et légumes bien
malin vraiment bien malin qui pourra
comprendre les fluctuations du marché
les légumes baisse les fruits montrent
les fruits deux exemples les pommes et
les poires pommes reinettes revendu ici
six francs 75 voire comice vendu 6
francs 30 monsieur ses pommes et c'est
pour vous les avez achetés vous combien
au prix d'achat
les honneurs et net par exemple on les
appelait à 4 ans 30 avant jc et les
poires ça fait quatre ans loin le kilo
aussi bons bénéfices et vie si à 50% sur
rien sur les chiens d'accord et l'or
pour les légumes qui eux baissent à la
consommation est ce que vous prenez la
même marge de bénéfice ben on prend un
la main
la même marche ceci explique peut-être
cela
depuis le début de l'année les fruits et
légumes ont augmenté de plus de 20% au
niveau du consommateur
la viande de son côté a progressé de 11
à 12% depuis janvier avec une pointe en
septembre mais pour les bouchers cette
augmentation ne fait que suivre pour
cent près l'évolution des prix à la
production quoi qu'il en soit depuis la
rentrée il est impossible de suivre le
boeuf les prix se sont emballés à tous
les niveaux nous subissons alors dans
nos achats que nous pratiquons
radicalement votre principalement à
régis le subissons une hausse d'environ
6 % sur les viandes que nous restons pas
pour les délits non routiers
cette hausse les bouchers l'ont
répercuté sur leurs clients en jouant
sur les différences de prix entre les
morceaux libre 37 % de la carcasse et
les morceaux conventionnés 63%
mais le problème de fond reste le même
la viande est et restera toujours un
produit cher
la viande est un produit noble qui coûte
cher à produire c'est un produit
demandeur cher à produire
cher à transformer et cher a distribué
partout vous trouver de la main d'oeuvre
alors il faut comprendre même se
produira tout sur une valeur importante
que peut faire le gouvernement dès le
début de la semaine prochaine le premier
ministre monsieur raymond barre réunira
les ministres concernés d'abord on
essaiera de faire un diagnostic en effet
la hausse a surpris tous les experts qui
prévoyait un mouvement deux fois moins
fort il faut donc d'abord recenser les
anomalies en passant au crible les prix
produit par produit profession par
profession
ensuite on décidera des remèdes pas de
blocage général ne seront sanctionnés
que ceux qui n'ont pas observé la règle
du jeu et une fois encore la politique
des prix sera en question monsieur
raymond barre déclare est
fondamentalement pour la libre
concurrence comme instrument régulateur
mais les effets de cette politique ne se
feront sentir qu'à long terme aussi pour
pallier aux difficultés
le premier ministre fera à nouveau appel
à la réglementation avec ses limites
psychologiques car c'est une mesure
toujours impopulaires
et puis ces limites économiques car son
efficacité dépend des contrôles
or actuellement on estime que 15 % des
commerçants ne respectent pas la
réglementation actuellement en vigueur
oui je regardais le petit bilan des
départs en vacances parce que c'est un
long week-end qui se prépare et bien il
ya des bouchons partout il y en a à
paris bien sûr autour de la région
parisienne mais aussi dans les grandes
villes à lyon au tunnel de fourvière le
célèbre tunnel
bref ce week-end de la toussaint va être
très fréquenté sur les routes le week
end de la toussaint est un est l'un des
plus dangereux pour les automobilistes
c'est ce qu'a rappelé aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur christian bonnet
les routes sont souvent glissantes la
brume accompagne les conducteurs je
souhaite qu'il soit prudent
souhaitons le aussi et souhaitons que la
nouvelle portion d'autoroute inauguré
aujourd'hui entre tours et poitiers ne
connaissent pas la moindre égratignure
personne ne connaît ce nouveau tronçon
la prudence devrait donc être la règle
tours poitiers 97 km pour 54 francs ce
n'est évidemment pas donné
l'inauguration de cette liaison par le
ministre de l'équipement
monsieur fernand icare nous donne
l'occasion ce soir de faire le point sur
les autoroutes françaises et sur leurs
difficultés financières
et oui jacques poulx en 1983 la france
aura sa toile d'araignée autoroutière
cela permettra des temps j'ai encore
davantage la soif de bouger qui
caractérise de plus en plus les français
dès 1981 on devrait pouvoir aller à
bordeaux par l'autoroute et en 83 faire
le tour de france sans feu rouge mais à
l'heure actuelle certaines sociétés ont
honte où on tue de sérieuses difficultés
financières les tarifs sont pourtant
élevées disparates 12 centimes le
kilomètre sur paris-lyon et 34 centimes
sur biarritz frontière espagnole
en fait les prix de péage sont fonction
du coût de la construction de
l'autoroute
on sait maintenant que pour l'autoroute
paris normandie et pour marseille nice
l'état a accordé des avances de
plusieurs centaines de francs
l'état a également volé au secours de
lyon chambéry en garantissant des
emprunts supplémentaires qu'on dû
contracter les actionnaires des
négociations sont en cours pour tirer
d'un mauvais pas l'autoroute par inès la
véritable raison des difficultés de
certaines autoroutes et que le trafic
actuel ne correspond pas aux prévisions
qui avaient été faites
que va-t-il alors se passer au mieux
grâce à la garantie aux aides de l'état
qui ne sont que des prêts remboursables
par les sociétés
l'augmentation du trafic résorbera les
difficultés au plus mal certaines
sociétés peuvent se voir retirer
l'exploitation de leurs réseaux et qu'il
soit confié à un autre concessionnaire
l'augmentation du prix du carburant
l'accélération du rythme de la vie le
besoin de tranquillité ont favorisé
l'avion et le train
l'autoroute n'est cependant pas con
années elle a même encore souhaitant le
tout l'avenir devant oui attention je
vous ai dit 54 français 54 français pour
paris poitiers le tronçon ouvert
aujourd'hui tours poitiers ses 19 ans 54
c'est pour paris poitiers
là c'est bien clair le temps ce week-end
ce sera souvent très convenable mais
justement à cause de cela les orages les
brouillards peuvent tromper les
automobilistes avant de voir la météo de
ce week end avec guy la rivière un
rappel des inondations dans le gard
robert vernet car après le déluge dans
le sud du département à la suite
d'orages qui ont duré plusieurs heures
après les terribles pluies qui se sont
abattues sur le triangle
pont-saint-esprit par jacques bagnols
sur cèze le soleil est revenu ce matin
mais quel lourd bilan une nouvelle fois
deux cavaliers surpris par les eaux
d'une rivière en crue le vistre sont
morts noyés dans la région d'arles
les routes sont à nouveau ouvertes et
bien les communes sont sinistrées les
flots ont tout emporté
kas est broyé ils ont envahi des
centaines de rez de chaussée perturbé
les liaisons téléphoniques coupées les
routes et pompiers sont intervenus 150
fois et en sauver des familles
d'agriculteurs les cours d'eau sont
sortis de leur lit dans le secteur de
milo saint-gilles bellegarde et saint
louis du rhône dans les bouches du rhône
mais le ciel semble plus clément pour ce
week end
il
monsieur météo dites-nous qu'il fera
beau ce weekend mia pas pour commencer
en tout cas parce que je voyais tout
l'est de la france jusqu'aux halles et à
l'accord vient cette nuit et demain nous
allons avoir des pluies et peut-être des
orages vous ne pas rendre en mai 40 à
partir de dimanche devrait s'améliorer
sur ces régions avec des existe sur tout
le reste de la france tel temps
d'automne brune el mathari débrouillards
très fréquent attention par conséquent
mais l'après-midi des éclaircies dans la
mesure où ces éclaircies pourront être
bel et bien les températures vont monter
jusqu'à 15 degrés dans le nord de la
france et 18 d'olmix et puis pour la
dernière partie du week-end à partir de
mardi un risque de pluie
arrivant sur l'ouest de la france est
juste que cela en normandie donc
attention pour les retours et attention
aussi pour l'aller
en bref avec vous jean claude narcy des
autres nouvelles de ce journal françois
mitterrand et robert fabre vont se
rencontrer dans les prochains jours sans
doute à la fin de la semaine prochaine
afin d'examiner la situation politique
les deux hommes entérineront l'accord de
leur formation pour le premier tour des
élections législatives
cet accord comportera un certain nombre
de candidatures communes ainsi que des
prix mais le général félix malloum est
arrivé à paris aujourd'hui
il a été d'ailleurs reçu à déjeuner par
valéry giscard d'estaing avec lequel il
avait évoqué la coopération entre la
france et le tchad
les deux chefs d'état ont eu un
entretien de 45 minutes mais à sa sortie
de l'elysée le général malloum n'a fait
aucun commentaire sinon pour souligner
que les conversations s'était déroulée
dans de bonnes conditions
le maréchal tito a ajourné tous ses
engagements internationaux et cela pour
un temps indéterminé machin tito qui est
âgé de 85 ans a pris cette décision sur
le conseil de ses médecins
encore des choux et les choux-fleurs je
t'ai 50 tonnes ce matin dans la décharge
publique de châteaurenard dans les
bouches du rhône en quatre jours ça fait
300 tonnes de choux fleurs détruites
le prix du retrait était ce matin de 27
centimes le kilo alors que dans des
secteurs comme marseille
chaque chou-fleur et est vendu entre 3
francs 20 et 4 francs 20 kg inauguration
d'un temple bouddhiste en plein bois de
vincennes
c'est le maire de paris jacques chirac y
présider l'inauguration compagnie de
jean sainteny qui est le réalisateur du
sang les locaux culturels et cultuels
ont été installés dans des bâtiments
élevés pour le cameroun et le togo à
l'occasion de l'exposition coloniale de
le tout a été rénové par la ville de
paris
voilà le bouddha la campagne nationale
de lutte contre le cancer se poursuit
avec succès déjà près d'un million de
français ont généreusement répondu au
comité et d'espoir en envoyant la somme
de 15 francs
si certains d'entre vous n'ont pas
encore reçu dans leur boîte aux lettres
la fameuse petite carte verte est bien
une carte rouge est en vente
actuellement dans les bureaux de poste
au même prix de 15 francs
en retour vous recevrez un dossier
d'information sur tout ce qui touche la
lutte contre cette terrible maladie
spectaculaire incendie à barcelone dans
un grand magasin du centre de la ville
l'immeuble une structure métallique
s'est effondré comme un véritable
château de cartes en quelques minutes
miracle les clients nombreux à l'heure
du sinistre ont pu être évacués à temps
seuls cinq pompiers ont été indisposés
par la fumée mais le bilan est lourd 200
millions de pesetas ce soit un milliard
deux cents millions de nos centimes
henry kissinger a signé ce matin un
contrat aux éditions calmann lévy dans
lequel il accorde à cette maison le
droit de traduction de ses mémoires en
langue française la publication est
prévue pour dans deux ans nul doute que
les mémoire de celui qui fut surnommé le
magicien des diplomaties prendront place
parmi les plus importants documents de
notre top ce soir deuxième étape des
huitièmes six jours de grenoble en tout
1800 km hier l'italien moser champion du
monde
associé au néerlandais pigenel a
remporté la première étape devant les
belges merckx et circulent sont arrivés
troisièmes les vainqueurs de l'an
dernier bernard thévenet et l'allemand
aritz en football dans quelques minutes
c'est le coup d'envoi de la 14e journée
du championnat de france de première
division le leader nice effectue un
difficile déplacement à marseille alors
que son second monaco a beaucoup plus de
chance devant sochaux donc une
possibilité de changement à la tête du
classement dans tous les cas vous
pourrez voir ce soir des extraits de
quelques rencontres au cours de téléfoot
a présenté par pierre cangioni vers
22h35
et puis il y aura bien entendu un tiercé
dimanche à longchamp il réunira 18
partants et demain dans le journal de
jean claude bourret à 13 heures andré
théron vous conseillera pour choisir vos
cheveux
bizarrerie du show business le chanteur
de pop music qui vend actuellement le
plus de disques au monde 13 millions en
un an et presque un inconnu en france
alors que dans toute l'europe ces
spectacles se vendent en trois heures
il paraît que chez nous dans les boîtes
on a dansé tout l'été sur ses musiques
pourtant à ce que m'a dit à ce qu'on m'a
dit la france est le seul pays qui
boudent les hausses ailleurs il chantera
une seule soirée demain samedi au
théâtre des champs-elysées à paris
christian marquis soul a rencontré au
cours d'une tournée il ya quatre ans ne
le prenez pas très haut c'est un fléau
sawyer avait fait sa première apparition
sur scène déguisé en clown
mais les succès qui suivent comme you
make me feel like dancin
et d'autres encore on en fait un artiste
à part entière
en fait on découvre les eaux solaires au
8ème 64 c'est la révélation de l'année
en deux ans de léo sawyer influencé par
endel strauss et bob dylan est devenu
une vedette internationale
c'est aujourd'hui le plus gros vendeur
de disques du monde
chacun connaît une fraude oeil ses
chansons sans imaginer un instant que
c'est lui qui en est l'auteur le
compositeur et l'interprète pendant la
dernière saison discographique et plus
particulièrement cet été ses albums se
sont vendus à plus de 13 millions
d'exemplaires en france on se dit mme
star quand on a vendu 200 mille disques
la différence est bien grand ce petit
angle est aujourd'hui un grand artiste
de stan et se produit dans le monde
entier
son dernier caché à las vegas était de 1
million de dollars soit 500 millions de
ventes
c'est une sorte de nouveau monde sauf
sauf pour la france
et
habitat
il sera à paris le 29 octobre pour deux
concerts une venue discrète dans un des
plus petits théâtres de la capitale car
il a peur du public français c'est pour
lui le public le plus difficile du monde
voilà de temps en temps ça ne fait pas
de mal bonne soirée à tous au nom de
toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal avec jean pierre pernaut vers
23h30
merci